well six Western States including Nevada
agreeing on a plan today to drastically
cut their water usage from the Colorado
River however California not on that
list in the state is the biggest user
this comes one day ahead of a federally
mandated deadline the states were also
supposed to come to an agreement last
summer the Colorado River provides power
Farm irrigation and drinking water for
some 40 million people now Governor Joe
Lombardo sending out a statement on the
agreement saying in part quote I'm proud
that Nevada continues to work
productively with our fellow Colorado
River Basin states to update River
Management and secure the future of the
Southwest